[MUSIC]
You have to be comfortable with complexity
if you're going to work in Africa.
>> If you're serious
about changing things,
you first have to understand
why they are the way they are.
>> We love complexity, and we enjoy
taking complexity and making it simple.
>> Think about how difficult it
is to change your own habits.
Now expand that to an entire continent.
This is a challenge faced by
African e-commerce company Jumia.
How do you change hundreds of
years of established precedent in
how people buy and sell?
In many ways,
they've cracked the code, and
they've done it differently
than you might expect.
But if you ask them,
they've barely scratched the surface.
[MUSIC]
Welcome to Grit & Growth from Stanford
seat, the show where Africa and India's
intrepid entrepreneurs share their trials
and triumphs with insights from Stanford
faculty and global experts on how to
tackle challenges and grow your business.
We've got a bit of a departure
from our usual today.
This is the edited version of a live
event with accomplished businesswoman
Juliet Anammah.
Juliet is the chairwoman of Jumia Nigeria,
and
Chief Sustainability Officer
of the Jumia Group.
We spoke to her as part of the Stanford
Entrepreneurial Thought Leaders series,
which as you'll hear included real-time
questions submitted by viewers.
Together, we explored what Jumia has done
to convince Africans to adopt e-commerce.
How they're revolutionizing
informal markets and
how much more there
still is to accomplish.
[MUSIC]
I wanted to start by getting to know Jamia
and the problems it's trying to solve.
>> Jumia is an e-commerce
platform the largest,
e-commerce platform in Africa and
we started in 2012.
And we started with a very simple
mission that we could improve lives
with the power of the Internet
on the continent.
We are based in about 11 countries.
And the 11 countries where we're based in
actually cover 70% of Africa's GDP and
about over 500 million Internet users.
So the question is, like you said,
what's the problem we're trying to solve?
If you're a seller in Africa many years
ago, you only have two options on how
you're going to retail your
products to consumers.
Either you had to pay a very expensive
high street real estate prices for
a modern retail shop.
Or you had no other alternative but to
operate in the open market, very informal
open market is hot it has no amenities or
utilities and it's overcrowded.
Those were the only options
you had especially if you
were a small medium enterprise
just trying to get by.
So Jumia solves that problem for
a host of millions of SMEs, and sellers,
and merchants on the continent because you
don't have to register on Jumia platform.
You don't have upfront capital expenditure
in terms of putting on retail space.
Literally minutes once you're registered
and gone through the training for
selling online on Jumia you
can start your business.
So that's a huge part of the problem.
The second part of the problem of
course was a logistics problem.
So the first one was
a distribution problem.
And even just stain on the distribution
one, if you were consumer by the time
you finally buy the product, chances
are that markups from the very long
distribution chain from manufacturer
to org breaker, to wholesaler, and
finally to retailer and the neighborhood
shop, where you buy the item.
You could be paying significantly
more than you should as a consumer.
So, one was a distribution problem,
from the consumers perspective and
from a seller's perspective.
So, we're bringing in millions of
consumers to interact and transact with
sellers directly, with no intermediaries
or any other agents in between.
The second part of it is
the logistics part of it.
We also solving a logistics problem by
integrating multiple logistics partners
into one single integrated logistics, used
to be called in my old accent is as a 4pl.
But what it is,
is that you're using technology to
integrate different asset owners.
And then using Jumia's technology to also
manage the data and how they operate.
>> So, Jumia doesn't own the logistics
supply chain, but it has a platform that
allows you to get the right players
in there when you need them,
where you need them.
>> Exactly, so it's an asset light model.
You have people who have the assets,
you have people who have tricycles, and
vans, and so on.
But what was lacking was always the
technology to integrate that together and
to use the data to make quality
decisions of where do you deliver,
what timeline is that,
required and so on and so forth.
>> And what point is Jumia decided we
should build this in house versus we
should partner in?
Is that conversation ongoing or
maybe that's a trade secret, but
I'm just curious to know.
>> You have to be comfortable with
complexity if you're going to work in
Africa, okay?
[LAUGH] We love complexity and we enjoy
taking complexity and making simple.
So, like I said earlier
the problem is not assets,
the problem is not people who have
warehouses and hubs, all of that exists.
You have people who have warehouses,
we have people who have hubs,
we have people who have ten trucks or
some people who have five tricycles,
we have all of those assets that exist.
So replicating on the asset
side is not creating value.
The real asset that then drives
e-commerce is the engine,
which is really the technology, okay.
So, how do you know which day of the week
you can make certain deliveries?
What is the speed of delivery?
How do you do your routing so
that you're more fuel-efficient?
You also reduce distance traveled.
All of those are relevant information you
cannot get through just owning the assets.
You get that through owning
the technology that puts it all together.
And the value is the fact that all those
players are utilizing your technology.
So you have the delivery agents who have
your delivery app on their mobile phone.
You've got the third party
logistics players who are using
your hub management system
in their businesses.
>> This philosophy, to connect what
already exists rather than start from
scratch extends beyond logistics.
Jumia works with third party companies
to facilitate payments, and since their
apps are already familiar to the customer,
adoption is relatively seamless.
And what about payments?
I mean, I'm really curious because
I love this transformation.
I want to get back to
the transformation that for
the informal sector that's implied
in everything you just said.
But what about payments?
>> So payments was another part of it.
Because I still remember about 2015,
just not too long ago,
if a consumer made a purchase on Jumia,
and we relied on just payment through
a debit card or credit card,
I had to clear on the backend with a bank.
Sometimes if there was a return,
it could take two weeks because of course,
the banks at the time e-commerce was not
really something that they were really
focused on.
So we had to do develop our
own payment system, again,
using the same principle of integrating
different payment methods that
a consumer could have into a seamless
platform that are allow us to clear
whether it was credit card, or debit card,
or mobile money, or bank transfer.
Whatever payment method
that the consumer had,
we could also integrate
it on that network.
So that's the third component, and
that's why those are the three parts of
our ecosystem I want to dig down a little
bit more into the payments piece.
I'm going straight into
the weeds loves to be but
are you using third
party payment providers?
I mean, there's so many startups now
in this FinTech space in Nigeria.
There's a lot of venture
capital flowing in.
I mean, I've lost track of him any of
the mark, are you doing your own thing or
you're working with all of
these third party providers?
>> We're agnostic, so we're working
with all third parties, yeah.
And especially given how
large the market is,
the real value you bring to consumers is
not limiting them to your own solutions.
It's actually giving them a platform
through which they could use
whatever payment
methodology that they have.
[MUSIC]
>> E-commerce is relatively new in Africa.
And platforms like Jumia
are transforming the informal market.
One example access to information.
>> It's huge, I mean, because look at the
number of sellers in Africa who are small,
medium enterprises in the informal market.
And then when they get on to Jumia look
at the the kinds of information that is
available to them.
Suddenly they know for example,
what which ones of their items are fastest
moving, which are what price points.
Which particular color if you're in
a fashion if your fashion seller and
Jimmy is suddenly new,
whether it's the blue shirt or
the red shirt that actually sells better
than the other SK use that you have.
That's very powerful information.
They get information in terms of
given the placement of the products,
the product information,
which they put up on site.
They get information on their
seller score and all that.
So really formalizing informal trade
is what, it's a huge huge benefit
that an E-commerce platform Nigeria is
bringing into to the sellers in Africa.
So that's a huge part, that's a really big
transition from where they were before.
>> So that I love that, that's
the data analytics piece which is for
some of them I think probably
data they've never had or
they had intuitively or
they had it on paper and pen.
Can you tell how many of your
sellers are new sellers, I mean,
in other words that they would not be
in a marketplace if it wasn't online.
>> Yes, there we ran a survey recently and
we have sellers in between 30%
to 40% of our sellers, who say,
look you know they started their
business exclusively on Jumia.
Right, and some sellers start
their businesses on Jumia,
some sellers came to junior
to expand their businesses.
But what I actually find extremely
interesting is the number of women's
sellers that we have on Jumia.
So we have at least in Nigeria and
Kenya which are key markets about
51% of our sellers actually women.
Why do women find it attractive?
It's a gender agnostic environment.
You could be a fashion seller,
you could be an electronic seller and
it's not a physical market where someone
can make those kinds of gender related
decisions or what I want to buy
an electronic product from a woman or not.
So that has given them access to different
categories that a good performing.
Two, it's also given women flexibility
to be able to manage their homes and
at the same time run
a business of their own.
Then third components that women say
they really appreciate selling on Jumia.
It's Mr training, training on digital
marketing training on how to sell
online training or
even how to read your account statements.
Just those basic kind of training.
The importance for an SME,
just cannot be overemphasized.
>> I love that point.
We're always trying to get more
women CEOs into our program, and
we Commissioned a study to look at what
are some of the barriers to entry for
an entrepreneurs across
the African continent.
And you just sit a bunch of them
access to capital, like if you want to
open a storefront, it's going to be super
hard to find that 50,000 $100,000 loan.
The second is access to networks.
Women traditionally,
in not just in Africa but
across the world have
trouble accessing networks.
And then the third is
access to technology and
I include training under technology,
right?
That is the most basic technology you're
not getting the same opportunity, so
those are really powerful
elements of the platform.
[MUSIC].
>> We've talked in recent weeks about how
technology based lenders are changing
the landscape for SME finance and Africa.
Jamia has their own credit platform,
called Jamia lending.
I wanted to know how they
approach lending differently.
>> So Jumia Lending connects sellers
on our platform, leveraging their
transaction data, transaction history,
to then find working capital loans
through all the financial services
providers who are partners to Jumia.
So we don't lend off our balance sheet we
do the connection to financial services
providers.
>> It makes total sense to me because in
interviewing a number of FinTech CEOs for
my Podcasts.
They're all using algorithms and
machine learning as alternative sources
of data for assessing creditworthiness.
And the number one thing they use for
little working capital loans for
trading companies and retailers is
what's your repayment history And
it's not coming from banks because
banks aren't doing $500 ones, right?
But the other one would be
what's your revenue, right?
So if you can show that from Genea,
hey, I am, this is my monthly revenue.
That's usually valuable to those FinTech
algorithms because that's the data
they need.
That's interesting.
>> Let's talk about COVID for
a second, how important was
COVID in the lockdowns the determining
factor in the growth of E-commerce?
Is it just a blip in an otherwise
rapidly growing bow wave or
was it determinative in your growth?
>> I think it was a blip in Africa.
Look at it in the US here.
The US government more or less
bankrolled retail during COVID, right?
So put money in people's accounts and
you're sitting at home
what are you going to do?
You have to spend the money online, right?
So the Fed bankrolled [LAUGH] retail
during the pandemic you don't
have that equivalent in
other areas like Africa.
And in some cases where we
had intermittent, lockdowns,
and movement restrictions so,
it wasn't such a big factor,
in terms of growth of E-commerce rather
E-commerce had been on a trajectory.
Given the fact that you have
over 500 million internet users.
Africa is also a mobile first environment,
right?
So it's almost like Africans
have been hungry to
do more with their mobile phones.
And E-commerce just happened
to be one of those areas.
If there's any area where I think
there was a lot more awareness during
COVID about the potential of E-commerce
it's in the public policy and
public agency environment.
Where they suddenly realized that this
is something that can actually be
leveraged in a situation like a pandemic,
and has great potential for
jobs, and great potentials for
economic development as well.
[MUSIC]
>> Juliet's transition from CEO
to chairwoman of the Jumia group
has necessitated a shift in focus from
the company's present to its future.
How Jumia will fit in the landscape
of African commerce in how to sustain
the business model long term.
That means engaging with a wider
ecosystem including government.
>> In speaking with a lot of tech
enabled companies FinTech, Med Tech,
Health Tech the observation is that
we recognize that there's a role for
regulation to protect consumers.
The problem is when the regulatory
authorities are not at the cutting edge of
what's happening.
So the regulations themselves, even if
they come from a place of good intention,
they may actually be a hindrance or
a barrier to growth.
And so, what's needed is a dialogue.
And so my question to you is,
is there a group of, Of companies and
people like yourself who
are collaborating to work with
regulators to say let's
get this right together.
>> Definitely, so just on the context,
people say that regulators are not on
the same plane but it's our responsibility
as private sector to educate.
And a lot of my work in the past year and
so has been that education
providing information to say,
look, this is what we're doing.
And to a large extent, we've actually
spent more time just explaining this is
what we're doing, this is what
a marketplace model looks like.
These are the responsibilities of
the platform versus the seller,
versus the consumer and all that.
So I think it's our responsibility
as private sector to do it.
And that's what we've been doing, okay?
In some of our markets also,
we've formed coalitions with like
minded private sector companies.
In Nigeria we have the E-commerce group
within the Lagos Chamber of Commerce,
I am actually the first
chairwoman of that council.
In Kenya,
we have a Private Sector Alliance, and
we have an E-commerce
sector within the alliance.
So all of those are opportunities
to engage with regulators.
And it's always to the interest of
private sector to engage early that way
you can provide the necessary information,
and education,
and dialogue, because they want to do
the right thing they just want to be
well informed in taking
the right decision.
Sometimes you provide parallels from
other markets you can show what's
going on in US or China, and how
the African environment is different and
you make your recommendation and
they listen.
>> You are responsible for
sustainability for the group.
What does that mean for Jumia?
And what are some of the key
initiatives that you're focused on or
the organization is focused on
in the sustainability space?
>> The first thing for
us is actually very clear validation
that our mission itself is sustainable.
We don't have to invent some
new projects to go after.
I mean it doesn't mean, of course we would
have to operate in a sustainable manner,
reducing in terms of our shipments,
reducing use of packaging materials and
all that.
So all of those are very important hygiene
factors which we build into our day to day
operation.
But just realizing that our mission,
which is about in the end,
when you look at is about reducing
inequality is so critical and
is a big part of how we create value, and
how we create sustainable improvement,
and quality of lives on the continent.
And asking ourselves what more
can we do with that mission?
And second part of it is that
we have a full ecosystem of many
partners that working together can
actually create more value for
the communities that we live
in than just Jumia itself.
We have sellers,
we have third party logistics partners,
we have brands who work with us.
So that's a full ecosystem that if we
deploy can actually do a lot more for
sustainability.
So that's our focus, and that's our
area of attention for this first year.
I mean, this is the first year that we're
actually putting together our practices,
what we're doing and
we would have our first report next year.
A very practical example is how many
sellers on Jumia are classified as SMEs,
how many sellers on Jumia
have been able to get
access to working capital loans
to grow their businesses?
How many sellers on Jumia are women,
how many of them have utilized
the training facilities that we provide,
how many of them have utilized the loans
to be able to grow their businesses?
Those are huge,
huge areas of sustainability that we
haven't even scratched all of it right.
Let's utilize what we have first and
then there are all the levers of
which we can also concentrate on.
So those are some examples for you there.
>> There's a great question here.
I'm going to jump in on this one because
this is actually direction I wanted to go.
How does Jumia evaluate markets for
potential entry?
And do you ever decide
markets are no longer viable?
The person who's asking this question
mentions that you may have pulled out of
Cameroon.
I want to tack on my own question to that.
You mentioned you're in 11 countries,
500 million people and counting for
some enormous percentage of
the total GDP on the continent.
Can you go to this question and talk a
little bit about the barriers to regional
expansion and what you look for
when you pick a new country to enter?
>> The question that was actually right
yeah, we had to pull out of Cameroon.
Remember there was a time when Cameroon
the internet was shut down for
almost a whole year.
Okay?
These are very important
factors that we look at.
We look at the state of the economy.
We look at beyond GDP,
beyond economic factors.
We're also looking at readiness for
an internet based business like ours.
So those are very important nuances
that we consider in terms of looking at
expansion.
For now we're deepening our footprint
within the countries that we are in,
maybe in the future, but they're certainly
for this year where we're really
concentrating on those 11 countries
where we're currently in.
All said and done, we are the largest
E-commerce platform on the continent but
also in a continent where E-commerce and
I would say all of modern trade is
probably still within the ranks
of 2 to 5% of total retail.
So you still have a huge upside huge,
huge upside.
So before it's up tinkering with
all kinds of categories and
new verticals and so on,
just given that alone is a significant
area to focus on, and
that's what our focus is.
And I think the other thing we are
focusing on as well is really the shift
that consumers have made
from using E-commerce,
coming to Jumia to buy the electronics,
they wanted to buy products of high
value because they could get it
at a good price on Jumia and
they could get quality assurance and
all of that to their everyday products.
So people want to buy food, people want to
buy essential items, home cleaning agents,
beauty and perfumes, consumables
basically that's a huge shift and
that's where we are also
deepening our presence in.
>> I want to go to your competitive
landscape in a second, but I want to pause
and talk about consumables because one of
the things that makes consumables possible
here in the United States is that
you can get it tomorrow, right?
You can get your vegetables,
they're still fresh,
they're maybe even cold packs right?
You need a toilet roll, you need
cleaning products, whatever it is.
Is that a big deal,
is that important to your consumers that
they get something really fast or not yet?
>> Yeah, there's always a trade off,
sometimes it's the consumers
living environment that flows
into their expectations.
Okay?
So because in the States
right next to corner,
there's either Kroger or
there's a Target or
there's a Wegmans or any other brand
that you can pop into and buy.
So that flows into consumer
expectations of when do I want it?
I want it like in 10 minutes.
Of course you can use Instacart as well
and you get the product very quickly.
In our environment is slightly different,
consumers are making trade offs and for
them it probably the pricing
is more important.
>> So I got the perfect question here for
you that just follows on this, as part of
your impact goals that should be, do you
have any special role in supporting or
facilitating local manufacturing in
the countries where you operate?
We work very closely with brands, so
we have several brands
that are listed on Jumia.
And we see an increasing interest from
brands to be on Jumia for many reasons,.
One being of course,
that it gives an opportunity for
them to go direct to the consumer,
through Jumia as a platform.
Two it gives them very useful consumer
insight, and a lot of that consumer
insight is in terms of packaging in
terms of product specifications.
All of that is useful for
a manufacturer in development and
product development and, production.
So the answer is yes,
local manufacturers find,
being on Jumia extremely useful for
their demand planning and production.
[MUSIC]
>> Let's pivot a little bit
to the competitive landscape,
who are your competitors?
Is it kong.com or take a lot,
other e-commerce companies that
are in the continent or,
is Amazon a threat from afar?
>> I think when you look at
it at the end of the day,
competition is more the,
informal market, right?
Because all of that put together you've
just talked about whether it is Konga,
or Takealot.
Or any other, platform or modern,
brick and mortar retail and so on and so
forth, all of that like I said
earlier just 2 to 5% max.
The real competition is
the informal market and
we are everyday working to bring more and
more sellers to the platform.
And bring more brands to the platform,
excite more consumers where we currently
have a Black Friday campaign on,
it's usually is a very exciting period for
consumers
>> I had no idea that existed on your
platform.
>> We were the first to
launch it in Africa in 2014.
[LAUGH]
>> Around here that's when I try to go for
a hike in the woods because
it's too mud everywhere else.
[MUSIC]
Let me ask a bit more about where
does Jumia look for its vision?
Do you look more to the east, know,
Chinese e-commerce Taobao or
JD or Doe Yen, or
do you look more to Western models as
you think through your growth strategy?
>> I will say we're much closer to the
Asian Alibaba model because we're more of
a marketplace.
But then there are, structural
differences between Africa and China.
Some of the infrastructural
developments even things
like having a national postal system.
And driving down the cost
of postal services,
some of those things which Taobao,
for example, leapfrogged,
in developing in China,
we don't have those in Africa.
So, we look more at our consumers I would
say in terms of what are the expectations,
what are their needs, what's evolving for
them in the market what's critical.
[MUSIC]
>> Brands have started selling
directly through social media,
cutting out the middleman.
I asked Juliet how social commerce
factors into Jumia's future plans.
>> We view social commerce as
complementary to some respect in the sense
that, there's a lot of social
commerce on WhatsApp and Instagram.
But, it's also exposed some of
the challenges of social commerce.
In terms of protection of consumers,
sometimes you order something and
it doesn't get delivered.
And you don't have a system where by
you can trust in the returns process,
you can trust in the quality assurance and
so on.
Every time we pull out consumers they tell
us that one of the things they really
really love on Jumia is,
they don't want to deal with a seller
they don't care who the seller is, okay.
I mean and I'm speaking figuratively,
the person they have
a relationship with is Jumia.
And so if something goes wrong they
want to know that as junior they're
dealing with.
We always talk about the fact that
when you're ordering online that many
things will provide the items for
BBQ seed.
You can see the sellers score, you can
make decisions between multiple options,
which seller to go with,
payments and all of that.
So, there's a whole lot, there's riding or
just completing the purchase
online that consumers like the option
of having someone, the intermediary,
the platform that is taking some of
those responsibilities for them.
>> One of the biggest hurdles for
any e-commerce company,
is building trust that if I give you
my money, you'll send the product.
This is especially true in markets where
those online buying habits haven't been
well established.
I asked Juliet, what has Jumia done to
create trust with buyers and sellers?
>> For any market place of course you
would have issues sometimes with sellers
and so on and so forth.
But like you mentioned,
we do have recourse mechanisms.
We have penalties, we score sellers
by many things by speed of delivery,
by the quality of the item,
by the return rate of the items
that they sell on the platform.
So, many things are built into it,
and of course we have seven
items which must be Q seed.
We have manufacturer warranties and
we offer everything that you can
think of from a recourse perspective.
And for some of our consumers also
depending on the type of item and
the specific consumers
behavior on our platform.
Sometimes the consumer wants
to return something and
we refund immediately even
before the item is retrieved.
Okay, so they're many things we've
build into creating an environment
that consumers can trust and
feel comfortable, to shop online.
>> We've heard a lot about what Jumia has
done to change the commerce paradigm in
Africa.
And as we wrapped up our conversation,
I asked Juliet how much she thought
e-commerce would actually drive
development, across the continent.
>> I mean it's already contributing
to development on the continent.
There was a BCG report that talked about
the fact that look marketplaces like Jumia
by 2025 could be, contributing almost
3 million jobs on the continent.
So, in terms of you're talking about jobs,
that's one.
Number two,
you're talking about formalizing
informal retail like you mentioned.
You're also recognizes another area,
which is the cross border
trade within Africa itself.
So those are many pathways and
many areas in which e-commerce and
companies like Jumia can make a
significant contribution to the continent.
>> We tend to think of
these shifts as inevitable,
a byproduct of technological advances.
But I think jumia shows how much careful
thought and effort has to go into solving
a host of problems in traditional,
largely informal markets.
Their commitment to using existing assets,
and
working with partners who are already
on the ground, has eased adoption.
Trust was built with tools for buyer
recourse, and access to information for
sellers.
And collaborative work with
regulators will help solidify their
standing as they create their own
paradigm for commerce on the continent.
But Jumia is not alone, although
the potential Pan African market is huge,
there are many new and some established
players competing aggressively for it.
I do wish Jumia all the best
as they seek to scale.
Thanks to Juliet Anammah of the Jumia
group, and to Luke Saikora and
the Entrepreneurial Thought Leader Series
for organizing this conversation.
If you'd like to check out the full talk,
you can go to the Stanford Ecorner YouTube
page, or
follow the link in our show notes.
[MUSIC]
Women in the workplace face unique
challenges and opportunities, that's why
I'm excited to introduce two programs,
designed for women leaders like you.
Offered by Stanford GSB
executive education, and
led by Maggie Neal and Deborah Grunfeld.
High potential women leaders is a live
online program, and the executive program
in women's leadership,
is a one week on-campus program.
Both equip you with the tools and mindset
to fundamentally change the way you lead.
Visit Stanford GSB Women.com,
to learn more.
I'm also excited to share with you that
season two of the Grit and Growth podcast,
we'll feature interviews with both
Maggie Neil, and Deborah Grunfeld.
[MUSIC]
This has been Grit and Growth with
Stanford Graduate School of Business, and
I'm your host, Darrius Teeter.
If you liked this episode,
leave us a review on your podcast app,
it really helps us to share the stories
of these incredible entrepreneurs,
with as many people as possible.
To learn how Stanford Graduate School
of Business is
partnering with entrepreneurs
throughout Africa and South Asia,
head over to the Stanford seed website,
at seed.stanford.edu/podcast.
Laurie Fuller researched and
developed content for this episode with
additional research by Jeff Pickett.
Kendra Gladich is our
production coordinator, and
our executive producer is Tiffany Steve's.
with writing and
production from Andrew GANIM and
sound design and mixing,
by Alex Bennett, at Lower Street Media.
Thanks for joining us,
we'll see you next time.
[MUSIC]